good afternoon I'm Jim Plummer the Dean
of the engineering school and I'm
delighted to welcome all of you here
this afternoon we're here to celebrate
Morris Chang as one of the engineering
heroes and this is a program that's been
going on for three years now we have
about twenty eight or nine engineering
heroes and these are people who have a
strong affiliation with Stanford many of
them are graduates others are faculty
who've served here for a while but
they're people who change the world in
various ways so we're talk a bit more
about Morris in just a second but but
let me begin by recognizing several
other people who are here John Hennessy
who is president of Stanford University
also an engineer and and in just a
couple of minutes Jenson Wong will get
up and make a couple of remarks about
Morris as well and Jensen is also an
engineer in fact a Stanford engineering
graduate so so unlike many of our
previous engineering hero
[Applause]
that was that was actually in my next
paragraph here but but I'll do it again
good so I also wanted to note that most
of our engineering hero events actually
have been evening events but this one is
actually being held as part of a regular
Stanford class the entrepreneurial or
thought leaders class and so we're
delighted to have all of the students
who are part of that class here to help
us celebrate with with Morris this
afternoon we have also a number of TSMC
executives here we're delighted to have
all of you with us and we also have a
number of people from the global
semiconductor Association including Jody
Shelton who was helpful to us in
organizing this event as well so the way
we're going to proceed this afternoon is
that the main event will be a
conversation between John and Morris
we'll leave time at the end for
questions for those of you in the
audience you might have interesting
questions or comments to make but I did
want to say a couple words about the
about the engineering heroes program
before we do that so as it's as I said
there are roughly 29 people we
recognized at this point as heroes of
the School of Engineering the latest
class of people includes the founders of
Google Sergey Brin and Larry Page Sally
Ride who was an astronaut and a
proponent of science education and
historically people like Fred Terman
Bill Hewlett Dave Packard and Vint Cerf
are also on our list of engineering
heroes as you go at the auditorium at
the back to the right there's a wall
there that has a plaque actually for
each of our engineering heroes so Morris
is a Stanford PhD in electrical
engineering and Oh since you got me off
track I forgot the paragraph so I did I
did want to recognize not only your wife
Sophie but also Jensen's wife Laurie
more delighted that Laurie could also be
[Applause]
so Morris is a electrical engineering
PhD from Stanford and he's Jensen we'll
say a bit more about him but he is I
think best known worldwide really well
known worldwide for transforming the
semiconductor industry and it was a in
some sense a single idea he had back in
the 1980s that made this big
transformation and at that point in time
people companies that design
semiconductor silicon chips and so on
and by and large had their own
fabrication facilities big factories so
they would design them and make the
chips and more has had this key insight
that you know maybe with these factories
getting to be as expensive as they are
perhaps we could actually share the
manufacturing facilities and enable more
people to build these things that
perhaps couldn't afford to build their
own semiconductor factories so that was
the origin of TSM C which is the company
that today is clearly the world leader
in building chips for what are called
fabless semiconductor companies now the
consequence of that has really been
transformative because not only did it
result in lower costs for many companies
but it resulted in a wave of creativity
and innovation because people could now
start a company designed to design
semiconductor chips and do it with a few
people and and count on a manufacturing
arm at TSMC to actually build the
components that they would think about
designing so he he transformed in in a
very real way the same mcduck Terr
industry and I'm sure John will talk a
little bit about him that talked a
little bit about that within this
afternoon so with that brief
introduction let me ask Jensen Wong who
is a graduate of the also electrical
engineering department here at Stanford
just to save a few words because he
knows Jensen he knows Morris really
quite well and he was going to say a few
words about his relationship with him ok
good afternoon
first first of all both Jim and John
like professor Plummer professor
Hennessy that is excuse me we're both of
my professors and I don't know if any of
you have been so fortunate to have been
taught by either of them but I am rather
the product of your work so if you're
and you know so this is what it looks
like when we grow up
Moore's
the world is full of successful people
frankly but heroes are rare and I think
that we understand the difference
between the two there is a difference
between success and impact and I'm
really I'm really glad that that this is
partly a class because I think that
Moore's
his career his philosophies TSMC its
strategies its core values is absolutely
a study in Industrial Revolution there
is no question about it and all of you
who are interested in starting companies
changing the world building things that
matter
this this is a wonderful study of that
impact there are very few companies that
I know that any one of you know in fact
who has had a greater impact on society
as tsmc when I met Morris almost 20
years ago the concept of building
semiconductors the concept of building a
chip starts with build a factory the
first thing you do is find R&D engineers
find enough money to build a factory and
if you have any money left
you would actually build a new
application
a new chip that mattered what Moore's
mores did with TSMC his insight was
instead of being a product company TSMC
would be a platform company it would
build no product it would enable other
companies to build products that incite
all although so clear now potentially
one of the most sustainable
semiconductor manufacturing business
models going forward the foundry
business model was absolutely unclear
then was absolutely unclear then if you
look at their impact today over twenty
some thirty billion dollars in sales
almost a thousand customers instead of
manufacturing one or a few products very
very well
they manufacture umpteen thousand
products at a time this is a company
that manufactures that makes something
that I have utmost confidence right now
as I speak that every single person in
this audience has hidden his possession
this is the only company that I know
that at this moment there's something in
your position possession right now that
is manufactured by them I believe that
to be a test that will pass whether you
have an iPhone or Samsung Galaxy or an
iPad or whatever it is of all of the
companies you know in the world this is
the only company that currently has
something they make in our possession
right now there are no others so there's
basically air and tsmc
I believe I believe that passes the test
I believe that passes the test of impact
but what's really amazing is this what's
really truly amazing is this I met I met
Morris when I was quite young and in
fact I've known Morris my entire company
career and video today wouldn't be here
if and nor nor the other thousand
fabless semiconductor companies wouldn't
be here if not for the pioneering work
that TSMC did and the pioneering work is
not semiconductor manufacturing the
pioneering work is the strategy of
semiconductor manufacturing they decided
there would be a platform company and in
that platform company description'
technology matters capacity matters
pricing matters delivery commitments
matter but the one thing that I took
away from our meeting and I tell
everybody this almost 20 years ago was
when I went to see him
in Hsinchu my walkaway message was one
thing this is a company that had
technology they had capacity their wafer
prices were relatively low they promised
to deliver on time but my takeaway
because it said so in the brochure it
said so in all of my conversations with
Moore's and assess so in and everything
he said over and over again was what's
gonna make TSMC great is integrity and
Trust and it sounded at that time when I
first met you Moore's and don't take
this wrong sounded a little cliche
because everybody says that but here's
the fundamental difference between what
he said and what he meant and why it was
so important to TSM see if you are a
platform company and you are a platform
by which other
company's dreams are built from if they
can't trust you you cannot be there
platform it's no different than the
ground we stand on a foundation we stand
on a continent we build we immigrated to
if you can't rely on the fundamental
foundation of that country that
infrastructure that platform you can't
build an ecosystem above it
20 years later TSMC is not only a great
company I've already talked about its
impact but it's business philosophy has
become so foundational to an entire
industry whether it's EDA companies or
IP companies that are in the audience or
fabless semiconductor companies there
are no industry no company no products
that I know of that tsmc is not somehow
involved in and it came from that
singular vision that trust and integrity
was foundational to their business let
me just give you tell you a couple
stories I have no more a long time and
and I have a lot of business stories but
they're not very interesting I have I
have some personal stories I think
you'll find interesting and it says
something about his commitment and his
courage hard to say hard to tell which
one is which at the moment as I tell you
the story you decide I think it was 19
1990 1999 you will know the date but I
think it's like 1999 and it was a Friday
afternoon I got a phone call my admin
says Morris would like to drop by to see
me on a Friday afternoon and was like
might in my last meeting and I and I was
expecting TSMC sales to accommodate him
but he showed up by himself it was him
his pencil in his black book every time
he pulls out his black book had always
sent chills through me not not not
because not because he needed it for
everybody who knows him he's impeccable
with numbers
he's impeccable the numbers he probably
still remembers how many wafers I needed
that year but he dropped by and and he
wanted to see me and we talked and he
asked me about business into new
products and and my wafer needs for the
year coming and and he wrote it down and
we had a nice chat and he left
nobody had TSMC knew he came I found out
later that he was checking up on his
customers and in this case it was me and
and he was on his honeymoon and and I I
am one I'm one of the few people in the
world that can say I
I was with Sophie and Moore's on their
honeymoon that's my first story I can't
tell him it's a story of commitment or
courage hard to say III wanted to pick a
good story that exemple or both my
second story was this is just a few
years ago and usually Morris sends an
email says he'd like to like to chat and
then we talked on the phone and he he
had an announcement and this this
announcement is that he is going to have
a career change he is going to be the
CEO of TSMC again and I and and at first
at first I was happy for him and while I
pretended to be happy for him and and
the first thought was isn't there our
driver's license that you have you need
for do be a CEO of a company and he's
turned thirty seventy five this is a guy
who can write on his resume when I was
75 I applied for a job as a CEO and got
it
[Laughter]
and and I you know I I think that there
are many CEOs in the world there are
many as successful people in the world
and and we all love what we what we do
we love what we built but very few
people at the age of 75 or maybe it was
76 comes back to take on a massive
company with global scale with just in
the middle of Industrial Revolution
which is doing to mobile revolution and
not only that he delivered what I would
estimate to be the best five years of
his career and it's a little bit like
Jack Nicklaus two weeks ago saying you
know what I think I want to finish all
the rounds of the Masters and win it so
this is this is an extra yeah being a
CEO as you know of a new large
enterprise is mentally physically
challenging I mean this is a
full-contact sport and to do it to do it
now and to do it the way that you've
done it's really really extraordinary
Maurice I want to say on behalf of
everybody here that we've seen a lot of
success over the years but we've never
seen impact like what you've made and on
behalf of all of us you're my hero
[Applause]
well after that I'm not sure what else
we have to talk about Oh fine but let's
start with the point that Jenson made
the tremendous impact that TS LCEs had
not only in the creation of the fabulous
semiconductor industry that I think
couldn't exist without without that
leadership but also the tremendous
impact it had on the Taiwan
Semiconductor Manufacturing and really
being the spearhead for the growth of
that industry did you anticipate those
kinds of changes when you began the
company did you think you could have
that kind of impact around the world no
not at all John actually the very idea
the new business model the pure-play
foundry business model now everybody
thinks that it was a pretty clever idea
but at the time it was really a solution
that was looking for a problem because
as Jensen said it would say it was meant
to be a platform the problem was that at
the time nobody needed a platform there
were very few fabless companies being
existence at that time there were maybe
20 some fabulous companies now even
those fabulous companies did not think
that they needed a tsmc it may they they
felt that they would rather go to
Toshiba an easy Hitachi Fujitsu or even
Intel or TI for fab service foundry
service now of course I mean those big
guys the Japanese companies the Intel's
and TI's really didn't want them you
know and they would make stuff make
wafers for
for the the little fabulous companies
only any very steep price not a
financial steeper price but the price of
wanting their designs for their own
selves for their own product sales but
still we were not trusted enough our
technology was not just enough that they
would come to us and the big companies
awfully obvious didn't need us now so it
was the solution waiting for a problem
to happen now the problem happened
pretty quickly in the early nineties and
I think that our existence
certainly helped to accelerate the
formation of a lot of service companies
there were maybe 25 fabrice companies in
the whole world in 1985 86 and then 10
years later there were 400 500 fabulous
companies and some of the big ones were
started in their parent in that 10 year
period I mean having worked in a fabless
companies involved in starting two of
them one before TSMC that had to do
exactly as you say go form partnerships
with the big players who this was not
their primary business and then forming
one Atheros with the SMC yeah day
completely different kind of experience
yeah yeah right right so I'll talk about
that talk about the impact on Taiwan as
well I mean the catapulting of of Taiwan
into the semiconductor manufacturing
business in a big way I think in many
ways we were the first in Taiwan we were
not the first semiconductor company in
that one how I had other semiconductor
companies before TSMC started them but
we certainly became the most successful
another company in Taiwan after a few
years after only a few years and also we
I think that we really set a model I
hope for Taiwan in hope at governance in
innovations
now most most almost 95 99 % of Taiwan
companies operate with health in gross
margin and gross margin 4 or 5% and they
don't have money for aandhi they don't
even have money for service marketing
for for heaven's sake with 4 or 5
percent gross margin them and we I
believe we're the first company that
showed them that to to be a world-class
company to be a real successful company
you need to have on the you need to have
good sales marketing and and because you
needed to have Rd your gross margin
would would have to be in the 40 50
percent range right yeah so we I think
we set the first example and on
corporate governance
you know believe that we we set an
example also so I think PS MC did begin
to apply a different meaning in
pawa as a corporation yeah so tell me I
think Jensen alluded to this focus and
you said it to pure-play this focus on
manufacturing excellence Rd and
manufacturing designed to bring new
semiconductor lines to to production
faster how did you get decide to focus
on that but how did that become the
central focus point for TSMC well
because one thing one reason in fact may
be the principal reason was that I at
the time I started a tsmc I had already
worked in the industry semiconductor
energy for 30 years right I joined the
industry in 1955 and started the tsmc in
1985 and I had already been the head of
the largest semiconductor operation
business in the world
Texas engineers so there was a song
dynasty Chinese poem that said that that
to be the leader the first thing you
have to do is to climb to the top of a
high building and look down on all the
available roads in the world
and I did that actually at TI I a Q PI
perhaps the most the height the height
of the industry and looked at the the
all the available roles and there wasn't
really any for a newcomer to compete you
know
so I to figure out a new road and the
new road was this new business model
yeah but then of course the problem was
that it was a solution looking for a
problem but happily the problem occurred
you know I think Jason was was one of
the problems yeah but I think you
understand this point Mars because there
were some earlier attempts at silicon
foundries but they had mixed business
models they were CAD tools combined with
companies that had manufacturing lines
or they and they never put the focus on
manufacturing excellence
I think Jensen hit on trust you want you
want your customers to trust SMC you
know better be manufacturing sauce yeah
I that certainly and III mean I owe a
lot to a lot of people I a lot to my my
own family my own early upbringing which
did instilling me values of integrity
and being trustworthy and so on I owe a
lot to the education I received Stanford
and Stanford I although I spent only two
and a half years well I should I must
mention Harvard and MIT as well all
right but but but the the the two and a
half years I said I spent a Stanford
getting my PhD I think were very
important years decisive years for me
because I I had started to work already
in the seminary before I came to
Stanford for my PhD and I I have to say
now that before I started working my
studying at MIT was
really not serious I really didn't know
what I wanted in life but then I started
working and I knew what I wanted now
when I came to Stanford I have been a TI
I've been in industry for six years
already and I have been a TI for three
years and I was on the rise at TI and
they sent me to Stanford to get my PhD I
already knew what I wanted and I I was a
very very diligent and serious and
hard-working student the only time I was
a hard-working diligent service so I'm
sure the students would like to know the
secret of finishing a PhD in two and a
half years freaking delusion and how
tell me how the pieces of your education
fit together as you said you were at
Harvard first and then you you switch to
MIT but yeah and then and then and then
went to work before you came here you
know how did what happened there why did
you switch from Harvard MIT or it's not
such a bad place to get a degree no it
was in fact even even now I consider
that to be my most exciting year it was
ours freshmen I just spent a freshman
year but remember the time was 1949 to
1950 and there were very very few
Chinese there were there was no Chinese
American Chinese American politician
there was no Chinese American even
businessman there were Chinese American
laundry people there were Chinese
American restaurant people
now the only really serious profession
was a middle-class profession that a
chinese-american could pursue in the
early 50s would be technical you know
research or or development engineering
work yeah
so although although Harvard was at
first was a very exciting year but the
Harvard didn't even have engineering as
a special as especially poverty and the
undergraduates were general education I
didn't think I could find a job a good
job anyway if I got a bachelor's degree
at Harvard so I switched to MIT the
second year and I switched to mechanical
engineering yeah and then as I said I I
really wasn't all that interested in in
mechanical engineering or engineering at
all I was a lot more interested in in
politics business economics general
things you know so that's why I Harvard
was far more interesting to me the MIT
turn out to be but I actually I went on
of course anyway and the in fact I
wanted to get a PhD at MIT however I
failed the PhD qualifying exam
and they they allow you to take it twice
you know I think it's the same Ruis
Stanford there they allow you to take it
twice and if a I've had both times so
what was I to do and I decided that I
would just go to work and I was kind of
sick and tired of mechanical engineering
anyway so I I went to work for a new
semiconductor company Sylvania and then
after three years as Sylvania the new
semiconductor division of Sylvania after
three years and I remembered one classic
address that the general manager of that
division gave to all his interact
employees and and there were maybe 150
of us well we were gathered in the
cafeteria and he said he made one
classics comment that I remember to this
day he said I'll trouble all trouble as
Sylvania is that we cannot make what we
can sell and we cannot sell what we can
make ever since then I tried to stay
away from that
a TI later
and of course NGS MC and I've I should
say I've successfully stay the way yeah
let's white guy and tsmc around so tell
me about and tell me about the time when
you first when you first returned to
Taiwan you have those tremors went with
Y oh yeah right yes went I did Taiwan
was a strange place to me yeah a new
place in a strange place when I first
went there in 1985 yeah yeah so and that
was the first time you had actually been
there well I had visited times a button
so you returned to head III to head this
industrial ride route that you ever
Manhattan right yeah I mean about that
time and how that influenced your view
of the semiconductor industry and what
could happen in Taiwan the imagery it's
a tea tree history had had a
semiconductor pyro line actually
semiconductor development project for 10
years ever since 1975 from 19 1975 the
the premier of Taiwan the Prime Minister
of Taiwan had the foresight to start a
semiconductor development project in
Taiwan in itchy in this Industrial
Technology Research Institute in in
Taiwan and it get if God is technology
well is sent out invitation for bits for
people American companies to transfer
technology semiconductor talon ii ii ii
ii issue and there were several bidders
and the winning bidder was RCA so a tree
got its
technology early technology CMOS
technology from RCA and then from that
point on they started to follow to
continue to to develop their technology
the problem was that it was only a
development project so the RCA
technology was about one generation old
anyway one generation behind when it was
transferred to a jury and then when I
arrived in 1985 which was ten years
after they started they had become two
generations behind in spite of their
very hard work but the you know they
just couldn't keep up with the with the
technology problem was that a a that
most other semiconductor companies in
the u.s. at that time did so we we
started tsmc started with with that
technology with the III technology which
was two generations behind the current
technology but we managed to to start to
catch up on and I would say the it took
us perhaps 10 years the first ten years
of tsmc and now of course you know we
had we we start to have enough business
volume to support a a much higher level
of Rd then it recruit young so how do
you the thought of starting a
semiconductor manufacturing company and
the capital that requires seems quite
daunting how did you how did you get
that company launched well the
government first promised to BD to be a
50% the largest investor 50 percent up
to 50 percent
and so it was my job to get the other
50% of course it turned out that even
though the premier promised that the
government would invest of 50% in TSMC I
still had to get the bureaucracies
agreement which was took actually model
not just a few months but also a lot of
heartache you know a sensation yeah
but of course the harder part of course
was to get the other 50 percent and and
the premier told me that I needed to get
the a a technology a multinational
technology company to be an anchor
investor and then if I if I get this
multinational technology company to be
the anchor investor then it would be
easier he would help me to get the rest
from Taiwan business community so I
spend about about eight months to get
Philips well actually I have written
letters letters to a lot of people Intel
TI Toshiba Hitachi and you see Sony and
actually three companies gave me
presentation opportunities Intel did you
know I wrote to Gordon Moore and Gordon
robach said he said that I I have asked
Craig Barrett who was at that time his
CTO I think to see me so I taught to
create twice two separate occasions but
at the end of the second occasion he
said no when I interested
and TI the same way saw him twice salty
I tried I went to Dallas twice long and
the same way at the end of the second
meeting he said no mark Shepherd said no
[Laughter]
and then but the only company that
appeared to be interest genuinely in
stress was Philips interesting yeah and
well I had wanted somebody better in
technology and Philips in terms of
semiconductor technology I had described
them as being in the first role of
second-raters but I had to said oh I
have to settle for them yeah yeah I'm
Justin I got them and they invest the 28
percent so I had 48 percent it turned
out to be 48 percent from the government
Taiwan government 28 percent from
Philips and then the remaining 23 24
percent I guess I got from from about 12
or 13 companies and that was very
interesting to what what generally
happened was that one of the ministers
in the government would call a
businessman in Taiwan and the podium
that he would send me to give a
presentation to that businessman to get
him to invest so I was on that kind of
trip so you know a dozen times and there
was one pretty big investor a 5%
investor that they actually bought when
the Minister of Economic Affairs in tawa
first saw him
and podium that you want to send me he
said okay so I went there actually three
times three separate times and in the
year and yet he and his staff sat down
with me for dinner and none of those
people knew anything about
semiconductors they will keep quizzing
me you know at dinner and I I didn't
even I wasn't even able to I didn't even
have time to eat anything but and it was
you know price this happened two times
dinner two times dinner and
interrogation and then he called the
Minister of Economic Affairs the big the
big businessman called the Minister back
said no no no I'm not gonna invest well
the minister of course was unhappy but
he told the premier that the premier
said let me call the sky and so the
premier told me later that he called the
sky and he the premia also told me he
said I told him the government has been
very good to you in the last 20 years
you better do something you better do
something what I gonna now look at this
you look at what's happened historically
it's really fascinating because in the
in the late seventies and early eighties
I think the there was this thought that
Japan would take over the entire
semiconductor industry yeah and in fact
that hasn't what's it that has not been
what's happened in fact there was a
surprise of tsmc in Taiwan semiconductor
industry then may now mainland China
Korea obviously how have you how did
this how do you see what what really
caused this kind of evolution and these
changes well I really think that the
problem with a
Japan where the Japanese industry was
that they never created a fabulous
industry
it was the fabulous industry in the
United States that came up with all the
innovations almost all the innovations
in the last 20 years so I mean there was
this industry Japanese semiconductor
industry conference all five or six
years ago and I was invited to attend
but I was not invited to participate in
a panel that they had so the panel the
panelists were all the Japanese
industrialists semiconductor
industrialists sitting up there
discussing that they wanted the
government to to fund a common fad for
them now like PSM see that's what they
said you know up on the stage and I was
sitting down stage I was very getting
very impatient but and then finally
finally they stopped talking and the
chairman of the of the panel as if if
anybody in the audience wanted to make
any comment so I raised my hand and they
all knew me anyway I said I don't think
your problem was was not having a common
fat huh your problem was that you just
never had a fabulous company it was the
fabless companies you know that the the
the the big difference that has occurred
in the last that remiel was I think
something like 2005
between 1985 and 2005 the 20 year time
period the Japanese market share had
dropped 20% 10 20 points and the
American market had gone up 20 points
and the fabulous in the meantime or
American went from zero to twenty
percent right right and that was the
difference yeah well not only did but
they also don't they also didn't go into
the hardcore foundry business the
pure-play foundry business which they
could have done they had the technology
early on they were good at the
manufacturing site but they they decided
not to do it I guess yeah I wouldn't
have welcomed them to right now you to
create a fabulous industry yeah that we
could then one thing III know that you
also have a great love and appreciation
of the Arts and and the amenities you
mentioned your year at Harvard tell me
how that's affected you your leadership
your the style with which you've led
tsmc oh it certainly has made my life a
lot more interesting I I do I am
interested in both English and Chinese
literature and I'm interested in
classical music so my whatever leisure
time I have I will read a Chinese
literature English in fact the two books
that I have were near to my bed may I
read them usually you know in the in the
hour or two when I was too tired to read
anything serious I mean the two books so
one is Chinese it's the red chamber
stream it is Chinese classic and the
other is Shakespeare's plays and and I'm
particularly interested in the in the
Shakespeare's tragedies and I mean
there's a lot of meaning I think a lot
of life lives lessons
in Shakespeare's play and I'm
interesting music I'm interesting
history in general in biography and all
those I think adequated you to to my
life's interest I think and I think that
my business experience I think benefits
from somebody's lessons that I learned
in our reading too I often compare I am
a student of the the Second World War
the the main battles and so on other
often compare the competitive battles
that tsmc goes through with the
competitors compare them with the the
battles in the Second World War starting
grad an analyst for the siege of
leningrad starting the Stalingrad was
was the one I was very interested in
because well actually the Midway the the
naval namely our battle you know the the
Japanese commander couldn't make up his
mind whether to keep the the bombers on
deck or the fighters on earth and he
changed it he change why you know that -
yeah he chanted he change it and that
that cost him the battle indecision is a
very bad thing so final question before
we open up the floor uh what advice
would you give to the students who are
here who seek to have some impact have a
life that really achieves achieves great
things and many of them will most of
them be in some engineering discipline
what advice would you give them learn
and think both are important
both are important boy well here I go to
a confusion statement learning and
thinking are both important if you just
learn and don't think then you quickly
become lost if you just think and don't
learn then you'll quickly run out of
material to think for we have 15 minutes
or so for questions and we have mics or
what do we have here Jim okay the
conditions you described it at the
founding of TSMC are very similar to the
conditions that exist today in the MEMS
industry any other sorry I have a little
trouble hearing yeah could you be louder
perhaps hello there is okay so I was
saying the conditions that existed at
the start of tsmc are very similar to
the conditions that exist currently in
the MEMS industry and I know they what
it was in memos so and I know tsmc is
doing business and MEMS now it's a very
small part of your revenue but I was
curious what your vision is for MEMS for
tsmc and particularly whether you think
tsmc can standardize MEMS the way it did
for CMOS technology candid eyes
standardized yeah create a standard
based technology on which thus that's
what we hope to do in fact that's true
is in a mark tamarcus yeah one of our
co-ceos yeah
yes and I I really think that mims is a
very major part of what we call general
the next big thing you know the current
big thing is all these smartphones and
tablets the mobile product what is the
next big thing well the next big thing I
don't know exactly what it is I guess
it's it's probably the Internet of
Things the wearables and those things
but whatever yeah I think I think it's
very probably the internal things and
wearables anyway
MEMS will play a big part in moves so we
we really have high hopes for MEMS T
SMGs I hope you meant well March you did
achieve this in the mobile industry in
the beginning there warn't standards
particularly for the analog side of it
and you needed analog to go into the
mobile business and you did become a
leader in kind of creating a
standardized platform that people could
design on and you this because you were
willing to collaborate yeah with the
early fabulous companies as they came
along and that's what we're trying to do
in MEMS so when you spun out of it tree
do you think that could have been done
just as a start or did was it really
important to have a government
foundation there and it kind of spun out
of that and the second question then is
is that a useful model to think in in
terms of manufacturing generally around
the world or especially in the u.s.
spinning out manufacturing capability
out of our National Labs I really think
that the Taiwan the PSM see it Rea
Taiwan is a three way in combination I
think that was a pretty unique one first
of all all right
go to Taiwan to a star TSMC at all I
went to Taiwan to to be the president of
education and I thought I was going to
retire in that job you know and the
person that recruited me to that job was
say did was not the same person that
asked me to start tsmc in fact the two
of them were not friendly to each other
in our Hana and the person that
eventually asked me to start tsmc was
unhappy because the other guy had
recruited me to the issue job and anyway
two weeks after I arrived in the Itchy
job this other minister who was unhappy
because he didn't recruit me asked me to
to go to see him and at that time he
said you always thought he s MC and well
of course he had he didn't really
understand semiconductor industry very
well
so when he said you ought to start a
semiconductor company he meant something
like the convention or IBM but but I
came up with a different with the TSMC
business model keep different game plan
and he had the confidence in me because
because he knew what I had done at TI so
so he trusted me so even though he
didn't understand what he found he was
he trusted me unique situation that
motley more generally I find it I think
it was a pretty unique situation you you
first you you have to start with the
insight that the power and government
had back ten years earlier in 1975 when
they started this to see the group on
this development group in history it was
pretty big money for them at that time
it was you know even just just the rc8
contractor the technology transfer
contract was four or five million
dollars which was big money for the
Taiwan government editor and then
sustaining their own debarment activity
and that probably cost the a few million
dollars a year you know and that was
pretty big money for the Taiwan
government but they did it and then of
course when the time came when I started
set up tsmc and the the premier the
second minister and the premier said
they would support 50 percent they
didn't know that it was when we 50
percent of 220 million they thought was
a much smaller number than that yeah but
they swallow that also so so I'll bet
they're happy they swallowed back oh I'm
very happy now yes recently some people
claim that beyond twenty nine twenty
eight nanometers the cost per transistor
is not gonna scale
they say that 28 nanometer is the last
technology note that has in it's going
to have basically the lowest cost could
you comment on that or do you repeat the
question is below 28 nanometers will we
get any cost improvements in
price of birth transistor some people
claim that's the end of the road in
terms of price drops per transistor well
I think it it does become more difficult
but I think it will still happen now now
I think there's the controversy going on
and whatever but I would say that it
will continue to happen will still get
lower lower cost transistor maybe not
the B creasing cost maybe will not be at
the same rate right has it happened
before Yeah right right
chairman considering your love for
literature is there an autobiography in
the works is it an autobiography in the
works
well actually I wrote one in Chinese in
Chinese in Taiwan appropriately so it
was the envy of the lot of professional
writers in Taiwan we sold almost 1000
copies which was a which constituted a
burger seller in in power and in fact I
had a trend I had translated into
English by a couple of professional
translators but I didn't like the
translation I didn't like the result and
Shakespeare wasn't available so I didn't
publish it I didn't publish the English
version huh yeah I think thank you I
think you'll like this one any advice to
a startup that specializes in buying and
selling primarily secondary
semiconductor manufacturing equipment I
was starting with a licen ship with the
SMC that
specializes in buying the selling of
used semiconductor yes yes and we just
actually start I do think there's a
market for that yes in fact you know
even even today if we will be
interesting buying some used equipment
but but whether I I would advise a
start-up like that
I I don't know I have to think about
that yeah but there is a market for it
yeah yeah definitely market other
questions yes so I have a question
reading if you read Macbeth just before
you go to sleep doesn't it give you
nightmares which is there i I generally
even though I'm primarily interested in
Shakespeare's tragedies but for bad time
reading cards romeo giulia all perhaps
the Merchant of Venice yeah I represent
the fabless industry we started a
company a semiconductor company in
Connecticut
Niva was trance which we used your
foundry and it worked out beautifully
it's a wonderful business model to have
fabulous in in your capabilities and as
you point out is key to the industry
itself but I want to thank you and keep
up your foundry
I also before we finish I also want to
say that the Jenson actually referred to
by being on honeymoon now when I talk to
my visits to him the Year by the way was
not 1999 it was 2001 now now but what I
want to say is that ever since then you
know I think Sophie support has been
very very important and when Jenson
refers to by last five years - five
years being the CEO again of tsmc
actually I didn't become CEO again at
the age of 75 as you said I became CEO
here at the age of 78 anyway last ten or
eleven years our actually 13 years I
think Sophie's support was most
significant I must picking you're right
the right life partner is another one
[Applause]
for you Morris
I was a non-technical and non-business
question how do you kick your smoking
habit I know you used to smoke when you
were in graduate school how did I kick
it yeah or you have ever kicked it I
haven't
I really haven't kicked it my my
philosophy on smoking is this I smoked a
pipe by the way okay yeah and I know
that the pipe smoking well possibly I
think is better than than cigarette
smoking in fact I have read statistics
not in the good column horse it's not in
a good collar well that's what you say
but the statistics I saw say that a pipe
smoker actually lives longer a nonsmoker
really yeah and the way I see it the way
are this is an e-journal for pipe
smokers the way I see it is that Wow
pipe smoking is injurious to your
physical health but maybe it helps your
mood yeah and and I I think it the a
presence of mood is very important glass
of red wine
[Laughter]
so dr. chant I have a question now
everybody knows you know these data
integrated circuits process you know the
circuit design complex is getting higher
and higher so the process is more
complicated but at the same time the
consumer electronics I are demanding you
know faster time-to-market
being able to deliver product in a
shorter life cycle so in your view how
do how do you or you know what we the
challenge facing forward and balance out
these two different requirements that
are coming in India John maybe yeah I
think the question revolves around the
complexity of circuit design and logic
design now with these complex chips has
become really significant I mean look at
Jensen's products for example and yet
there's demand to deliver products in
ever shorter periods of time how do you
see those two really meshing together
and being resolved well I think that the
there is a tendency that the Trappist
companies are consolidating you know I
think there'd be fewer in five years or
ten years
well I think some of them will be
acquired by others so do you think for
lady Armand Jasmine will be acquiring
people right you'll be alright
I mean will a model emerge I mean if you
look at how Intel does design they have
multiple teams working sort of been up
in a leapfrog fashion one after the
other because the design takes so long
and their apps will see more of that
emerge over time I have a question about
your decision of going back to Taiwan
you are a really very successful person
and p.i back in 1985 and what do you see
in time one that makes you give you the
courage you to go back to Taiwan well I
felt that them well actually at TI i did
not achieve what I wanted to achieve
which was the CEO job he only headed the
entire semiconductor unit but it honor
so now by 1983 I was actually told very
plainly that I would not be the CEO of
TI so I left in that year I went to
general instrument in New York to become
their CEO all with the expectation that
I would become the CEO in perhaps three
or four years now after year however in
general instrument although I still
could be CEO in another two or three
years but I decided I would not want to
be the CEO of general instrument so I
was now at a crossroads
I was in a company when I really
where I really didn't want to to be the
CEO no now at that time Taiwan began to
beckon so I decided that that would be a
good a it was it was a risk but you know
I was about I was 54 years old I felt I
could still afford to take a risk and I
had achieved a measure of financial
independence with my Ti and the general
instrument stock options all those sort
of things
there's nothing like what you would
consider wealth today you know but
financial independence to me meant at
that time that I didn't need a job we
could I could just live on the interest
of my the money I had which which was
true you know
so no interest rate was actually higher
that time - yeah but still still I
didn't for financial independence though
so I decided to take a risk and that
road less taken is what turns you into
an engineering hero I think it's really
remarkable
one more really quick question so I hope
it's a good one I hope to segwaying from
your point about the CEO so what are the
top three things or five things whatever
you want to share you feel is would be
important for a CEO I mean maybe you
know corporate and how study or five
things that you think are important for
being a great CEO all I of course it
depends on what kind of company you are
CEO of if if if is you talk about a a
reasonably big company let's say ten
billion dollars or not kind of company I
think a CEOs main job is to bring the
outside to the inside of the outside is
you know customers shareholders society
the world bring the outside to the
inside and maximize the inside
performance to cope with the outside
here I think that's the main job
so I'd like to just finish up by telling
Morris that those of you who have been
outside the back of this room and gone
to the right will have seen a wall that
has plaques like this honor for each of
the engineering heroes and so this is a
replica for Morris of the plaque which
is now hanging out there on the wall so
I'd like to thank Morris and John and
Jensen this has been a thoroughly
interesting conversation there is a
reception outside back for those of you
here in the auditorium those of you
watching over the Internet will will
have to presume that you aren't going to
be here but those of you who are here
please continue with us outside in the
in the reception area and thank you all
for coming
you